the Ramseys solutions Jeff and Ashley
are with us hey guys how are you where
do you guys live we live in Oak Park
Illinois so right outside of Chicago
absolutely cool welcome to Nashville
what brings you to Nashville you do we
attended your live event last night and
all right here to do our debt pre-screen
awesome very cool and how much have you
paid off we paid off twenty five
thousand dollars in about five months
way to go
making what kind of money we started out
making about 155 and now we're up to
about 175 excellent incomes way to go
what's your what do you guys do I am a
sustainability consultant and I'm a
structural engineer there we go just
like that and he's this young man and
how old is he this is Oliver and he is
17 months perfect very cool hey Oliver
how you doing that's fun so what kind of
debt was the 25 thousand well it was
about eleven thousand dollars in student
loans and the less the rest was consumer
debt okay very cool so what happened
five months ago that started you on this
journey
well we we bought a home and you know
handing over that the big downpayment
kind of drained our savings and I think
we had one of those moments where we
were like okay we've got to do something
so I actually started listening to you
in about 2007 on and off since then and
Jeff and I are both really digging the
podcasts so one day on our way into work
on the train I was getting ready to to
listen to you Dave and and Jeff was
getting ready to listen to this American
life and I said you know if you listen
to Dave as much as you listen to this
American life we could be in a different
spot financially and about a week later
he said okay I'll give you I'll give you
one year I give Dave one year if we're
in a different spot then we'll stick to
it ah and that started the whole thing
yep on the train yep there you go I love
it that's fine so okay so you plug the
podcast in and then what was your first
step what did you do
we actually had to drop our savings down
to a thousand you know which made us a
little uncomfortable you know but it was
really the first step and when Jeff
stopped his 401k contributions I knew he
was serious ah it's a big deal right
there definitely losing that match when
you know you're all-in yeah for sure
right and then we just you know we we
got some bonuses so we put that towards
the dead and then we just cut back and
our goal was to be done by Oliver's
first birthday just to start his second
year as a debt-free family and we paid
off the credit card about two weeks
before his first week I loved it well
congratulations so how's it feel feels
great you know good yeah you did it
really quick I mean five months that's
pretty impressive yeah I mean it was I
think with the big lesson we learned was
we have to incorporate some fun money
because we really cut back and that was
probably one of the hardest parts but
what was the biggest fight you had
during the five months I think just
getting started I'm you know more of an
engineer some more of a math guy and you
know going against the whole in the
highest interest rate first it was a
struggle um but just doing some googling
about your debt snowball
I found the study through Northwestern
University yeah you know looking at how
you know getting that motivation of
finishing debts versus just hidden that
a little bit really helps and so that
that kind of pushed me over the edge I
was like alright let's let's jump in and
do it yeah that's funny Time magazine
picked up that study and the title of
the article was turns out Dave Ramsey's
right that's pretty funny I've got so
much criticism from fellow math nerds
I'm one too and over the years of that
and it's it's pretty fun stuff
well congratulations so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
you paid off twenty five thousand
dollars in five months I think being on
the same page you know really as a
family agreeing on this is our goal this
is what we're gonna do and we're you
know I think together you can achieve a
lot more than each person trying to do
their own thing we asked you something
you did two or three things that went
against
your math intellect and you did them
anyway and you know you stopped your you
stopped your investing with the match
which is very difficult to do for guys
that are wired like you and me because
that's it feels like blaspheming it
really doesn't feel like you're doing
something wrong like God's not gonna
like you for doing that because you just
you you're losing it just it just
terrifies people that do math like us
you know yeah and on top of that then
you paid off your debts not by the
highest interest rate but the smallest
to the largest so you did two things
there that were counterintuitive and did
you now when you look back on it do you
see did you did you really see the lift
of doing that or was it just in my head
I think so I mean I really think for me
personally it was just really reaching
out and trusting my wife and like some
of her intuition because she like she
said she'd been listening to you for a
lot longer than I had and I was kind of
the one resisting and so I was like
alright I'm gonna trust you you know
follow this plan so it wasn't so much
Dave convincing me but my wife saying
yeah no but what I'm asking you now is
now because I'm the other side of it and
I look back and I see the value in it
and you're now the other side of it you
know even though you did something that
was counterintuitive obviously it worked
you got out of debt there's no question
about that but yeah but you missed the
match for five months yeah and did you
do you see the benefit of that now I
mean would you sell somebody else on it
now even though they were wired like you
and me and it was counterintuitive to
them I think so cuz I think just the
success rate is the sale you know I mean
I think we tried for a long time we
weren't crazy financially beforehand we
were always basically yeah sound but you
know we're trying to pay everything at
the same time and I think you do lose a
lot of the energy that you did
experience the power of focus
definitely then okay yeah that's what
I'm after yeah yeah I agree I wasn't
trying to talk into saying something
make sure it happened okay you know you
had this you made this great comment in
one of your podcasts what you do a lot
but in particular you said something
maybe you can help me out here but
you know when you when you focus a light
you can create a laser you know but or
you can use a light to light up a room
so I think that really resonated with us
and you know you know kind of cutting
out you know trying to do too much at
once and really doing one thing at a
time even though it's like you said it
goes against how he's wired he he did
commit he said I'll give you a year yeah
so he was rolling yeah that's fair and
the good news is you really only missed
five months of a match which really
probably is not going to affect how many
million jail too much and it is a
temporary stop of the investing and and
five months later you're debt-free so
congratulations you're very very well
done all right Jeff Ashley and Oliver
from Chicago area $25,000 paid off in
five months making one hundred and fifty
five to 175 a year count it down let's
hear a debt free scream why
very well done